aloha reject nation I'm Greggy
and I'm Johnny a talking like we're
talking do you see a clue we're gonna
watch we're the trailer for missing link
from Luca look at he split like us
missing link this is a film that some
people are looking forward to because
it's like people who watch like love
like they don't really get a lot of box
office attention you know what I mean
they're one of the two people it's not
hard but they do make really good stuff
most of the time unless it's the
boxtrolls from what I've heard
before I go into this I wanted to say
thank you thank you to all who follow us
on patreon because on patreon we do TV
show reactions for many a shows that
watch alongs
that includes attack on titan my hero
academia Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood as well as Gotham Riverdale
and supernatural and we also do weekly q
and A's and John does music video
coverage and every once in a while a
vlog that's very rare anywho let's watch
missing link religion tells the most
species a link between man
[Music]
excuse me hi yes I said but I don't the
greatest discovery of the century would
be
[Music]
[Applause]
quick quick quick sim once you give her
the kiss of night you're the man for the
job I think it might be a little too
heavy hard to know whose fault that was
let's do it again
[Music]
that's that Khalfan office I can't tell
who's supposed to be linked I just know
that Hugh Jackman's the dashing British
yeah yeah that looks fun yeah that looks
like one of their lighter I mean this
reminded me more of a boxtrolls than it
does like a Coraline wanted there I feel
like like a-- has done a lot of more
family accessible but sort of darker
more strange movies and this definitely
seems like one of their more fun and
light ones well I I bet that you know
it's like them I'm sure we'll still oh
yeah this could yeah you know yeah I get
emotional and they usually know how to
blend humor pretty well even well
they're a little more darker tails
[Music]
[Music]
and this looks fun they're the first
half of this trailer I couldn't tell are
these actual scenes or they make a
trailer like you know did you kind of
pick up on that are these actual like
dialogue moments in the trailer he's
like it the way it's very acting to the
narrator was like with the whole obit
and everything and don't breathe to the
future oh wait a second I said Oh like I
knew what you were talking about but I
know um I mean it didn't really make me
start like picking it apart that way but
I guess I can see why you might think
that they at least I believe it it's
it's kind of hard to tell
yeah I like the world exploration
they're doing here because it's you know
it's the missing link between past and
present yeah sure man and beast and you
know you explore a lot I'm kind of
skeptical and it'll is I'm sure it'll be
I'm sure be fun I'm sure I'll be funny
and I'm sure it'll be amusing regardless
I don't know it's like good to me their
story tellings a little bit you know
they're not illumination top-of-the-line
in terms of storytelling what I mean by
that is this seems like the kind of
humor I would eliminate illumination
whereas like I kind of hold their
storytelling in strips to a little bit
of a higher standard yeah and also I
mean granted all animation takes a lot
of time and a lot of manpower but I feel
like stop-motion you almost have to be
that much more sure that you have a
great script of some kind as you're
about to spend so much time compiling so
many frames of it you know
simultaneously for the marketing and
like we said beforehand that these
movies don't really make much money so
if they want to do better box office
numbers I imagine you have to kind of
make a trailer that is massively
appealing yeah and more along the lines
of the kind of animated movies that make
a lot of money but then know what eyes
you know
list that we had before I didn't really
catch everyone I mean do anything all
the fonts are really funny huge a
vocabulary no no no no give it all
you've got
and Zach Galifianakis so yeah maybe this
is just more among the comedy spectrum
in terms of its like wacky sense of
humor I don't know if I'm gonna love
this but I'm sure regardless it'll be a
really funny satisfying family film yeah
I can imagine this being quite
delightful and I don't begrudge them if
this is actually how this movie is I
don't begrudge them a shift towards
light because I haven't seen Kubo and
the two strings yet but I've heard that
as one of their more you know heavy
impactful movies yeah and so you know
wanting to do something a bit more light
and fun after that is not something I
think is a bad idea and I think you know
is something totally legit for them to
do yeah I just kind of hope that if it
is you know a fun more soft movie it has
all the same earmarks of quality that
they usually have because it's the thing
is again I remember the boxtrolls being
also one of their more whimsical and
more familiar ideas and that one didn't
pan out so well for them that's kind of
their lesser entry in their track
records so I hope that if this is in
that vein more that they improve upon
that kind of movie in their repertoire
yeah I'm sure this will be a really
funny movie I'm sure they'll be
entertaining and a heartfelt it's like
you'll try one the animations gonna
dazzle you yeah it always looks
beautiful
yeah I gotta argue for some reason to
him when I go on a like uh like this so
I was like oh never mind a learn a godly
complex lesson trailer expectation
versus reality of what the trailer is
alright guys well before I wrap this up
I want to give a patron of the day shout
out to a man named Austin Moore you guys
wanna have Hirst mention him before but
there is no better trailer to mention
him on than this he has a YouTube
channel you guys should definitely go
check out disturbed fan zero seven one
seven productions yep easy title to
remember I remember all the time it was
glad sound the computers printer fan
zero seven one seven productions he does
a lot of like Lego Star Wars
and films stop-motion animation which is
like like so if you like like you might
love mr. fan 0 7 1 7 productions you'll
like it or a God will strike you down
like he just tried to agree because you
haven't been watching enough of Austin's
videos and the Lord knows when you're
lying because he sees you when you're
sleeping and he knows when did you start
doing Lego remakes of like a movies
that's what I was I want a bunch of
stop-motion remakes of other stuff
action movies just so that we can get a
lot of people spending a lot of time on
the same idea all right well you guys
can't subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell and hey
check us out patreon we got [ __ ] bite